[Musique]
en 2014 l'Assemblée nationale crée sa
propre équipe de football composée d'une
trentaine de députés le fait d'avoir des
cardiologues au bord du terrain et aussi
des joueurs plus jeunes me rassurent
hier l'équipe de foot de l'assemblée a
joué un match caritatif contre
d'anciennes stars du ballon rond pour
lutter contre le cyber-harcèlement avec
pour la première fois des députés du
rassemblement national une nouvelle qui
n'est pas passée auprès des députés de
gauche qui ont décidé de boycoter la
rencontre le football c'est la tolérance
reconnaissance n'est pas les valeurs qui
brillent au rassemblement national un
bricode qui a agacé Marine Le Pen c'est
un concours de ridicule sans bilan sur
ses jambes c'est la haine tout le temps
partout
l'équipe des parlementaires c'est
finalement imposé et le match a permis
de récolter 35000 euros pour une
association mais la rencontre a surtout
été marquée par la blessure du député du
rassemblement national Julien Andrew
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors polémique d'Arca est blessure choc
retour sur le match très contesté de
l'Assemblée nationale
et Pierre Henri Dumont est avec nous
député les républicains membres de
l'équipe de France de football des
députés merci d'être la priori du monde
parce qu'en plus les républicains ils
viennent pas souvent chez nous
d'ailleurs en tout cas vous vous avez
compris qu'il fallait que c'est bien que
vous veniez parce que c'est vrai qu'ils
sont pas venus pendant les les élections
les a jamais vu on a vu le résultat
bravo à vous non mais c'est vrai au
moins les jeunes il a compris parce que
les autres ils vivent jamais venir donc
je sais plus qu'il y avait un truc
Pécresse avait fait face à Baba
elle est venue on la voulait plutôt elle
est venue plus tard voilà on est très
bien fait de venir Valérie on serait
content qu'elle soit venu mais c'est
vrai qu'il y avait un mec je suis plus
front que l'ouvrier ah ouais c'est ça
oui qui voulait pas qu'elle vienne bon
lui et de toute façon il fait de la com
de 1902 donc forcément remis le résultat
quand on fait 4 %, c'est vrai qu'on n'a
jamais raison mais en tout cas vous pire
Henri merci d'être là voilà ça commence
merci d'être là je te le dis merci je
pense qu'il faudrait que les
républicains viennent un peu plus nous
voir voilà
il est très content de vous avoir et
vous allez lire votre tweet j'ai trouvé
très bien je lis beaucoup de
commentaires sur le match de demain
l'essentiel est oublié nous allons grâce
à nos sponsors remettre un chèque de
35000 € à l'association i enfance créer
le boss pour nous pour faire oublier des
déboires internes et pitoyables je suis
assez d'accord avec vous je trouve que
vous avez raison là-dessus alors vous
allez nous en parler vous vous en pensez
quoi de la phrase de M Pokora qui a fait
énormément parler aujourd'hui on va voir
ce qu'elle dit mon ami mat qui a été je
trouve voilà encore une fois incroyable
regarde
surtout pour la bonne cause c'est déjà
ça aujourd'hui on dit souvent toute
l'année que le sport ça rassemble fort
rassembler les gens donc si nous aussi
on se met à commencer à faire des
différences entre les gens avec qui on
joue au football ça risque d'être
compliqué donc voilà je pense que on se
doit aussi de d'être là avant tout pour
l'association nous on est là pour mettre
des raclées sur le grand des raclées et
sont devenus
justement ce qui réunit dans le sport
c'est ça c'est que dans le sport on s'en
fout voilà on veut jouer avec plein de
mecs c'est ça qui doit nous réunir et
non pas voilà nous diviser et alors j'ai
vu plein de choses qui étaient choqués
de ce qu'a dit Matt Pokora donc Gilles
Verdez le relou de service il va nous en
parler dans un instant mais Pierre-Henri
Dumont qu'est-ce que vous en pensez non
mais il a raison en face ça résume à peu
près ce qu'on a tous pensé bon on
faisait ça on faisait pas ça pour le
plaisir de jouer au foot on faisait ça
parce que il y a une équipe de France
parlementaire de foot qui est là puis de
nombreuses années et on a à chaque année
une action qui est mise en avant là
c'est l'action pour y enfance qui gère
le numéro national le numéro vert pour
ces enfants qui sont victimes de
harcèlement et cyber-harcèlement on a
prévu au-delà du match de foot avec nos
sponsors donc de remettre ce chèque de
35000 euros à l'association pour
permettre aux enfants de pouvoir
s'exprimer un peu plus pour pouvoir les
sauver des spirales négatifs dans
lesquels ils peuvent être enfermés
au-delà des terrains de foot on a prévu
d'aller avec des célébrités avec ceux
participer au match d'hier dans les
différents collèges et c'est de
l'ensemble des circonscriptions de
France des joueurs pour aller dans les
lycées et je pense que qu’est-ce que
vous dites au socialiste aux parties
socialistes et aux députés des insoumis
de la nupes qui disent que fallait pas
jouer avec les gens du rassemblement
national
dans l'équipe le capitaine de l'équipe
moi je dis un truc je dis que le
précédent mandat on a accepté de jouer
avec les députés de la France insoumise
on a accepté de jouer avec l'extrême
gauche donc autant jouer avec l'extrême
droite à partir du moment où on accepte
là on doit accepter et puis surtout il y
a quelque chose qui est quand même un
peu plus important c'est que dans un
vestiaire moi j'ai pas demandé ce que la
personne en quoi la personne croit ce
qu'elle a voté aux dernières élections
le foot c'est universel c'est un langage
universel c'est le riche qui joue avec
celui qui a moins moyen c'est c'est
l'enfant qui vient des favelas au Brésil
qui joue avec les enfants de cadre sup
c'est ça qui fait qui fait la beauté du
sport c'est le plus beau langage en fait
même des gens qui parlent pas la même
langue savent parler la langue du sport
et si on commence à faire une
ségrégation et là on se retrouve avec
quand même la France insoumise qui est
quand même dans le comble de
l'hypocrisie parce qu'il nous disent
on joue au foot avec le RN on va les
normaliser enfin pardon mais c'est pas
en faisant une passe à un mec d'extrême
gauche ou d'extrême droite que moi qui
suis de droite je vais devenir d'extrême
gauche ou d'extrême droite
ça fait très longtemps que j'ai pas joué
à l'hypoglouton
parce que là où ils sont hypocrites les
insoumis c'est quand même temps ils
disent nous on est d'accord pour voter
d'émotions de censure pour renverser le
gouvernement avec le RN et par contre
ils veulent pas jouer au foot qu'est-ce
qui est plus politique renverser un
gouvernement
national en votant de motion de censure
ou jouer au foot mais c'est hypocrite
mais alors le seul qui dit non ici
c'est Gilles Verdez on va on va vous
laisser oui après on va savoir pourquoi
il dit non je vais prendre un oui euh et
je vais chauffer un peu Géraldine après
c'est à toi après c'est à toi je
rappelle les gens dans les prisons sont
des soucis si ma couteau les gens dans
les prisons sont des sous citoyens
Daniel et Lolo était allé trop loin vous
allez y aller mollo avec Géraldine
non peut-être qu'elle est pas d'accord
avec Daniel en ayant moi je trouve ça
d'abord totalement hypocrite il faut se
souvenir que par Monsieur Corbière et
Monsieur à Lyon ont joué au rugby
ensemble et ça ne posait aucun problème
à cette époque là il y a encore quelques
mois ça c'est la première chose je pense
que c'est juste une sorte de de voile de
fumée pour faire oublier la séquence
catastrophique du caca nains donc on va
se donner bonne conscience nous on est
dans le côté du bien de la bien-pensance
on donne des leçons tout ça donc ça
c'est insupportable là je pense c'est
ton avis je respecte mais je pense que
tu vas le manger pas trop pensé à ça
là-dessus dans ce cas là voilà
deuxièmement je trouve que là où c'est
absolument dégueulasse c'est que c'est
quand même un doigt un doigt d'honneur
et un bras d'honneur à tous ceux qui ont
voté pour le rassemblement national
c'est quand même voilà bah oui ça veut
dire qu'en gros vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas vous vous ne comptez pas on se
bouche le nez vous êtes juste nul et
donc on on veut pas de vous donc ça je
trouve que c'est c'est juste ignoble et
le troisième truc c'est en fait c'est
hypocrisie couine des socialiste en fait
Mitterrand à l'époque il était ami avec
vous et juste la vraie question que je
vais vous poser bah oui il en reste
encore des socialiste
dans l'équipe de France parlementaire il
y a car l'olive qui est député de la
majorité il y a Marietta karamani qui
est député PS c'est elle a pas pu venir
jouer parce qu'il y avait consignes de
la peau de l'ensemble des parties de
gauche avec Bousquet aucun problème
alors je suis en totale désaccord avec
Matt Pokora et très respectueusement
monsieur vous avez disputé le match de
la honte alors je voudrais dire si Matt
Pokora si Matt Pokora nous regarde c'est
une très bonne nouvelle que Gilles
Verdun sur pas d'accord avec toi c'était
dans le vrai parce que à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est très bien de travailler
dans l'hémicycle avec les députés RN
légitimement élus mais le football c'est
un symbole et la photo d'équipe avec des
députés du rassemblement national
toujours monsieur parce que cette photo
d'équipe elle est légitime vous avez
renié vos valeurs vous avez renié vos
valeurs en acceptant c'est les gens
comme toi qui font que la France est
divisée aujourd'hui
tu as tout faux on s'en fout on peut ne
pas partager le reste au contraire il y
a plein et tous les mecs partagent pas
l'oreiller en faisant ça au contraire
c'est là que tu divises les Français
c'est là que tu fais que des problèmes
aujourd'hui voilà qui sont insolubles
par des gens comme toi tu es tout ce
qu'on veut pas voilà je te le dis
Mathieu les gens qui pensent pas comme
moi je les combats sur le terrain et oui
moi aussi pas sur le terrain de foot
on les combats ici avec le débat mais ça
ça fait enfin pardon mais ça fait
maintenant plusieurs dizaines d'années
que les seuls trucs qu'on dit contre le
rassemblement national le contre
l'extrême droite c'est ah c'est pas bien
il faut les ostraciser moralité ils
augmentent à chaque élection donc un
moment donné qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ce
qu'on continue de dire il faut pas les
inclure il faut essayer écouter
si vous écoutez j'ai regardé vous avez
fait 4 vous allez faire deux prochaines
Gilles tu es comme les zones de la
France insoumise c'est-à-dire que non
seulement tu méprises mais pires tu ne
reconnais même pas les gens qui ne
pensent pas comme toi ou comme c'est
hallucinant c'est qui n'existe même pas
il devrait pas être sur la photo c'est
10 millions de personnes ils pensent pas
comme toi donc il n'existe pas ils ont
tout faux c'est complètement idiot
effectivement il faut débattre il faut
les reconnaître mais c'est vrai pour les
batteries il faut la reconnaître il faut
les avoir en face de soi pour ça faut
déjà accepter qu'ils existent parce que
tu n'as pas la pensée unique tu ne sais
pas tout on l'a déjà vu dans cette
émission en général tu sais rien Gilles
et puis en plus de ça s'il y a bien un
an d'amis
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont mais en plus il y a bien un endroit
où il y a pas de politique et on fait
nature il y a le sport blanc c'est le
sport dans tous les pays du monde
exactement et le sport
après t'inquiète pas tu vas voir tout le
moment après
Delphine
et toi Gilles qui es-tu pour exclure en
fait un parti qui représente et qui est
représenté quand même la moitié des
Français donc tu craches sur la moitié
des Français au bout d'un moment au bout
d'un moment on se le dise
si ce parti dérange et s'il n'est pas
autorisé s'il n'est pas légal qu'on
l'enlève mais qu'on arrête de de pouvoir
laisser certains Français le voter
c'est très simple ils ont été élus il y
a un match qui doit être fait ils sont
là il fallait pas s'ils avaient pas été
élu si les autres avaient été meilleurs
et ben voilà c'est tout ce qu'il faut se
dire voilà les gars c'est tout terminé
merci au revoir il y a un match de foot
qui doit être fait ils ont été élu ils
sont là ils doivent être dans le match
je te le dis c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui c'est ça donc et puis moi je
vous dis le foot ça doit rassembler et
moi je vous le dis moi moi comme on dit
ici on n'est pas des donneurs de leçons
euh voilà et et c'est insulté les
Français voilà qui qui votent pour un
tel point tel point tel nous voilà on on
peut ne pas être d'accord avec plein de
gens et qu'on a reçu ici d'ailleurs on a
plein de gens avec qui on n'est pas
d'accord sur plein de choses mais au
contraire de débattre je pense que ça
fait avancer des choses et ça peut faire
avancer aussi les choses de l'autre côté
et les faire réfléchir peut-être à
penser autrement là en faisant ce que tu
fais Gilles tu fais que faire monter les
extrêmes je te le dis voilà et c'est que
tu fais tout ce qu'il faut pas faire et
tu fais ce qui a été fait depuis des
années et toutes les façons toutes les
idées politiques et toutes tes idées de
de de voilà de vivre ensemble et ben
c'est tout fou tu as tout faux tu vis
dans les années 80 et tu es le résultat
de cette politique qui est nul depuis
des années et qui nous a amené à ce
qu'on est en train de vivre aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui tous les gens bah ils
sont voilà ils sont gays il y a des
trucs moi j'en avais rien à [ __ ] moi
quand j'étais petit de savoir qui voter
pour qui je voulais juste un mec voilà
qui était sympa avec moi je m'en foutais
qui s'appelle voilà comme il s'appelait
qu'elle était sa religion pour qui voter
je voulais juste des gens sympas et
qu'on kiffe ensemble il y avait pas de
racisme moi à l'époque on s'en foutait
voilà je te dis aujourd'hui à cause de
gens comme ça parce que tu
oses racises les gens et bah aujourd'hui
on se retrouve avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a des clans et
moi je veux pas de clan je pense qu'on
peut être tous ensemble surtout
aujourd'hui avec tous les problèmes qui
a dans le monde je te dis la vérité je
pense que tu es à côté de la plaque
excuse-moi mais je t'aime beaucoup hein
les terrassiste avec amnés
là j'avais dit que j'étais peut-être
allé trop loin je suis revenu sur les
propos après pendant mais Cyril moi
c'est pas du tout leur légitimité que je
conteste c'est cette photo d'équipe
c'est la collate
faut pas jouer au foot avec eux pour pas
leur faire peur mais je suis pas le seul
je suis pas le seul alors
polémique excuse-moi mon frérot mais là
tu as été là c'est assez limité
nationale quand même c'est pas moi tout
seul qui porte le oui cette polémique
c'est la question en général des
boycottes dans les événements sportifs
c'est une question qui peut se poser par
exemple avec le Qatar la Coupe du Monde
qui arrive au Qatar mais il se passe
quoi quand il y a des boycottes bah il
se passe que l'événement a quand même eu
lieu et qu'au final on se souvient de
pas grand chose mais quel est
l'événement sportif par exemple dans les
Jeux Olympiques où il y a eu le plus
grand retentissement c'est quand les
Jeux Olympiques ont eu à Berlin et que
Jesse a gagné
exactement le parterre de nazis
[Applaudissements]
j'ai réaction de mon ami mat et je
comprends tout à fait ce qu'il dit
maintenant ce qui m'envoie là c'est un
match de foot pour une association
croyez quoi à Matt Pokora vous croyez
quand il appelle pourquoi il sait très
bien comment ça se passe c'est ils
appellent l'agent de maths et il y a la
langue matte qui vient loin ouais tu
veux faire un truc pour une association
pour les enfants matte c'est un amour de
mec c'est un mec qui refuse jamais rien
pour les associations qui se donnent
tout le temps Matuidi ben écoute moi
avec plaisir j'y vais c'est quoi bah
c'est je crois vraiment que Matt Pokora
quand il est arrivé là-bas et lui il
s'est dit c'est pour la bonne cause je
vais faire ça pour des enfants tu crois
vraiment qu'il s'est dit ah ouais je
vais pas faire une passe à ouais ce gars
il est député de front de sale il s'est
du rassemblement national il sait même
pas tu crois quoi il vient il vient pour
la bonne cause ça lui retombe sur la
gueule c'est bon dommage sur la tête
excuse-moi le mec il est gentil il vient
il fait son match de foot il fait une
petite interview derrière il fait tout
ce qu'il faut et derrière il s'en prend
plein la gueule non mais et pense aux
enfants lui avant tout croyez quoi tu
crois il m'a dit ouais en gros il croit
ou quoi il vote voilà il me dit quoi moi
je vais au Stade de France je demande
pas à mon voisin en quoi il croit et
pour qu'il vote il a raison tu crois
quoi tu crois qu'avant lui faire une
passe excuse-moi tu vas te pour qui non
laisse tomber merci attends mais vous
êtes des tarés excusez-moi voilà le
pauvre il vient le mec il fait tout et
en plus mat vraiment
de mec il a jamais bougé c'est un mec
qui il a pas la grosse tête il fait tout
il fait tout bien il est c'est
incroyable c'est grâce à sa notoriété
qui a pas bien sûr exactement bah oui
voilà le mec qui fait tout il s'en
prendrait on part sur la tête ici
excusez-moi vous d'accord alors oui 79 %
voilà non à 20 %, c'est la famille de
Gilles allez